Okay, Al, if you could please introduce yourself with your name in today's date and
our location. I'm Albert C. Parr, we're at our home in
Gresham, working on these two at Avenue and the date date I believe is the 18th,
18th of June 2014. Terrific. Well, we'll start at the beginning. You were born in,
is it to Lee, Utah? To Iowa, they call it to Utah. Yeah. And so what was your family doing there?
Okay, my dad was working in the copper mines and a big army depot at the
12th, Ordnance depot during World War II. And after the war ended, decided he wanted to
leave Utah and move up to Oregon where his brother was, family was in
Rosbury. So we moved to Rosbury, I think in 1946 something like that,
1946 or early 1947, and that's why I went to all my schooling and grew up there in
in Rosbury. Did you have siblings? Yes, I have one brother, an older brother
and an assistant that's four years younger. And they both lived in the state.
My sister lives in Canberra, my brother lives in Lake Grover Lake, I'll swiggle.
So your dad was in the copper mines originally, but I understand he was in the forest
products industry. Yeah, he worked in the saw mills and plywood mills and the
Rosbury area and eventually ran a film station for a while and some other
things just sort of retired as a handyman and mechanic. It was a place there in
Rosbury. Growing up in Rosbury, did you have any, do you have memories of the
temper culture at that time? Yeah, there was a lot of, you know, that's what made
the world hum down there. And in those days, they were still giving a lot of those
first growth trees and it'd be Douglas Firswood. You take up a whole logging truck
the diameter would be and you'd see those coming down the road and the road is
really very primitive up in the mountains. There's a lot of them are at least gravel
not paid, but it was very primitive. But that was a, that was almost
excuse to be it. There's also a big farming industry in Rosbury in the garden
valley, a vegetable farming, can't load beans, that sort of thing. There were a lot of
less kids in junior high school, high school work in the farms and the in the
valleys there and in the Rosbury area. In fact that's why I started working in
the farming areas to save up money to go to Oregon State. So what, what kinds of
jobs did you do? Well I started the, you know, high school picking beans, the
pole beans and then eventually you got a, that was by a profound sort of job and
then eventually I got a job by the hour, sort of an overseer of that and also
the, and the swimming summers and running in Camel fields. And the guy worked
for about 25 acres of Camel open, tomatoes and strawberries and that sort of
thing and I would work all from, you know, spring on through the late summer
where we fall after school and on the weekends for the farmers. Was there much
migrant labor in the area at that time? Not much at all, very, very little. In fact
that's why the school, they used to run the school buses downtown and all
kids have to work in the fields and I don't think that's done anymore. I think
the children don't want to work out in the hot sun, but that's what it used to be
done. Back in the 50s and 60s and then before that it was, getting it
to get yourself into the school and the school buses load up and go to the
various bean fields and the work all day they bring you back to the school and
get yourself home somehow. When do you remember about your dad's work in the
sun? What was the typical work experience like for him? It was very hard work
and of course the mills were not air conditioned or heated or any of that
nature and so it was hard, it was hard dirty work and not the safest thing in
those days either, but it was very labor intensive. All the work was done by hand
and of course power saws that sort of thing, but you walk into a modern plywood
mill, there's very few people and it's all automated, but most days
everything was done by hand, including making the plywood sheet layer by layer.
Like I had a job one summer after in college working in a plywood mill
that was my job to make the plywood. It started out with the big flat piece,
a four-bed piece and put the machine just spit out glued cross pieces to
even slap those down some water and then flop another the sheets on and
physically built the piece of plywood with your hands and stacked them up with
put them in a big hot press and press them and started another batch, but it was
all hand labor you see, including the glued pieces and all parts of the
process were had so they employed a lot of people compared to what now they do.
Sounds a little repetitious. Yeah, it's boring but it was good money for kid
most day. How was your mother, what was her background? She was a school teacher and
so since we moved to Rosberg she got a job in looking glass, sort of teaching
there in looking glass and would go out there every day during the school year
and so we were very young so we were we'd often have babysitters and that sort
of thing and then eventually she moved to the Rosberg school system and retired
for 30 years or whatever. How was Rosberg growing up for you? I loved it
it was a you know safe place to be and had a lot of friends there still do so
have my road road contacts and we I liked it the weather was nice and it's
you know lovely place to live and of course a small town but I have very fond
memories of it. Really great place schools were good and so everything did
everything to recommend it in my mind. What were your hobbies as a boy what did you
do for fun? I was pretty busy working we lived on a small farm so we had
a lot of animals that always had pigs and chickens and now getting a cow on a
steer and that sort of thing so busy with that sort of thing and then hobbies
as I got older was cars got real interested in hot rod racing and a bunch of
was you know running these hot rods you'd see back in the 50s and drag race on
the on the roads and that sort of thing. That had a good time but it was it was
entertaining and it was a nice place to grow up. How about your experience at
school? The roastmen had good schools in those days and I've presumably still
do and so it was I learned a lot I was a for a few years for a few years of my
school and I didn't take schooling very seriously and I you know got by but and
nothing to nothing to brag about academic excellence but by the time I got to
high school and later on and I started taking school more seriously and
worked on getting good grades and that sort of thing but again they they were
very tolerant and I was active in student government in high school and so on
so I had a good time I enjoyed I look back with the high school with great
fondness I saw a lot of friends from from the Roosevelt graduating class and
I see them and I was just talking to one on the phone this morning it'll
be somebody from from Roseburg so you know your friendship lasted you know it
started last the last the lifetime you know from high school experience. They
seem education was an emphasis in your family. Yes I heard from the time I was
very small that you want to work hard so you can go to college and my dad
always say so you don't have to work in the mills like I have to work and what you
work in the mills you could see what he met and so what it was a good
impetus working in the mills and in hard labor on the farms that there might
be a better career perhaps more in terms of ease but also security because the
mills are always having strikes where there was before the union really got
strong and people get laid off and it was that it was not the most secure
environment so a lot of anxiety but for my father and the other parents as well
because of the changing nature of the scene in terms of the the mills and
who was oh who won't just when they buy some mills and everybody get fired and
so on and I could understand why my father was always apprehensive it was a
uncertain time. How did you develop your interest in science? I was always
fairly good at it always a math and then science things always came easy to me
it's just one of my buildings and I did well at it and I just got I was always
interested in how things work I built radios from time I was you know like a
teenager and you can't interest in radios not letting the interest you know
in physics and electronics and I always had that interest in high school and when
I went on to college that was the first thing I thought about it as having a
major in terms of physics and math so it's just I think things sort of selects
you by your abilities some people have great musical skills and other kinds of
skills language skills and there's some of us who have math and science skills
it just attributes and interest to and a firm believer in that there's
dispositions and characteristics of people that a lot of them to succeed because
some people no matter how hard they work have a very difficult time with mathematics
I would see that when I was teaching and there wasn't that they were you know
necessarily stupid people and they got that nature just they didn't have those
those particular abilities in perhaps interest with abilities and so people
tend to end up I think in things if they're going to be successful that they
have good abilities like that's what worked out for me and you know was there
anybody who during your high school time was a mentor for you or somebody
who got interested in these things or did it sort of my marriage from within
I had a series of very good science teachers in high school physics teachers
and chemistry teachers and math teachers I might add that always encouraged and
encouraged the students and then kept you on the straight now in terms of
the learning did a good job so I think the I had a benefit of a bunch of good
teachers most of the more veterans from World War II that was the ones I can
remember that had gotten to school in the GI building in one education they
were they were really excellent teachers a lot of benefit to us of students we went
to Oregon State College beginning in 1960 how did you decide to go to OSC? I had
a scholarship from the maybe and was in our TC scholarship and that was the place
that had that that program and also I wanted to major in a science program
so it was a natural choice and they had the in our OTC scholarship as well so
it was a confluence of events and interest as well as for this a little
scholarship aid was. Were you in in our OTC in high school? No no not at all but
there was one of those exams you take and you selected and so on I
know it was a competitive thing so that was part of your experience then in
college was being in the energy. In OTC? Yes yes as I was in that for two and a
half years then I decided that it would be better for me to continue in science
further than continue as a naval officer and a disenroll from that program just
used to sit my time in the science program. What did that program entail for
the Navy program? That would entail the summer cruises. After your freshman
year you went on the camp pedal and in some other places then after the
sophomore year we went to Texas for a while Air Force based on the
Corpus Christi and then another month or so at San Diego and so it's good
to realize experience I really think well those experiences in the Navy in the
summer programs and if I had stayed in the program the third year after your
junior year you'd be going to onboard a ship. Some sort of capacity but I
never went that far. I put some time in my junior year. Was there training
during the school year? Yes to the regular OTC program I think it was you had
to regular class three times a week then one day there was a drill where
you had to read out and it was a marching outside down there all those
fields or other buildings was down there the quons of that building really. It's
still the same building that it was like down there by the Colosseum and then
so forth. It was the same building that and those were all World War II
Quonset Huston so it's amazing it's still standing with all those fields
were all vacant there there's not a lot of the development that's we'd be out
there marching endlessly it's same. Yeah yeah there used to be quite a few
those quonset ads on campus I'm sure you saw. Yeah well what do you remember
about you sort of your first impressions of college and of Corralis? I liked it
I was I got there I was selected to go into some sort of they were trying some
living living living arrangements programs and they were also getting started
what they called an honors program at that time and I was enrolled in that
and they put people in that honors program as your freshman the whole
four on the first four Cawthorn Hall I believe. He was Cawthorn Hall. The whole
first four were people that were chosen for this honors program and they
encourage extra cultural activities and they had advisors and so forth and it
was pretty much a pretty nice bunch of fellows who had you know well fairly
successful in high school and they were then selected for this honors program
arrangement I don't know if they still do that or not I have an idea but it was
I was an introductory program so the people that we were my roommates and then
the people and the hall were pre-selected out by by someone in the university
as a part of this honors program to test to have the better students in one
location the people they perceive to be better students really ultimately turned
out or not I don't know but that was that was the idea of the time and there was
extra curriculum activities as well. Yeah and then the honor program you took an
addition to your regular courses there was at least one seminar a week of
you know small small bunch of people even sometimes one-on-one with one of
the professors working on projects. I found that very beneficial I worked with
biology botany and the botany professor once in physics professors and
entomology so it was it was an interesting time and did that every year for your
whole four years and then you would when you graduated you get an honors
designation on your diploma. Interesting see you're helping assist with
their research. Yeah you would do and then do little projects on your own yeah
and it was it was it was it was always sort of interesting and then just talk
about you know their field of research and then trying to learn a little bit
a little bit about it was a broadening experience but you got to work sort of
one-on-one with with the faculty members or in some cases one of my physics
program was working with a senior graduate student but coming once a twice a
week and we were working on on projects and the physics program. Yeah that's
I'm interested to hear you talk about this though there was I've known that
honors program apparently it started right around when you started it was
cut as a result of all at major five in the early 90s and then was replaced by
the University Honors College which came about five years later it sounds like
it's a little different yeah but your experience was yeah it was a you they
they in some of the classes are segregated in terms you know the people in the
honors program but by and large you just meshed with with everybody else and
did these extra things that with the seminars you know one or three are
similar credit course and get credit for that as well. It was a main
experience was being able to work with one-on-one with a with a research or
some sort of an extraordinary areas so it was a very beneficial. So when you went
to college is you have a sense of what you wanted to do in terms of your studies
because as a turn of that you took it I've looked at your academic records you
took a lot of classes and to get two degrees in four years was that your plan
from the beginning? I sort of liked it because I was the math and the physics
were happened to be easy for me and the things that caused me trouble were the
foreign language requirements that you know that was really hard for me that's
been probably more time on French when I was taking it then I then I did on
the physics courses just different abilities but no I just really liked
the physics courses I took as much as I could now select the math courses but I'd
taken a lot of math in high school I really liked it and they had some good
professors too in both departments it was a fun and fun environment so I look
back on my days both at undergraduate and graduate school with great
fondness because I enjoyed it and it was hard work and so forth it was a really
nice time you were doing something you really wanted to do and able to do and
sort of free from the necessities that happened to make a living otherwise and
work in a workplace and so on it was a time of your life and a pro-long time in my
case because I went on to graduate school where you were doing exactly what you
wanted to do and that's a that's a real good feeling it's very very good for the
soul did you have a sense of a particular specialty within math and physics at
that point in your life no I did not know but then in fact the curriculum was
sort of everybody took the same thing there were a few electors like in physics
you could take it maybe into meteorology or something of that nature or ocean
sciences was getting started back that some people would maybe take a few of that
but by large the physics curriculum was pretty well fixed and since I was
getting a math major too I didn't have a lot of a slop I had to take the required
courses and to fill the the social science requirements as well I think that
PE requirements in those days too that you had to take some of your classes
yeah I don't know if it was still current when you were in school and you
used to have to learn how to swim in order to graduate yeah and that was that
you had to take a swimming course and those days and I always thought it was
awful the no swimming suits you swam nude and I thought that was just
just a trotious I mean there's no earthly sense in it there was just some
very peculiar people running the swim program in the athletic department I
think that was my that was always my opinion just strange folks you're not the
first person to say that to me but were there any professors that made a
particular impact upon you you can think of yeah I like the entomology
professor I worked with John Latin I believe was the same was was very influential
got me interested in in philosophy of philosophy of science and a whole range of
things other than learning a very little about entomology but a little bit and
we had some good professors in the physics department to enjoy that a great
deal they were they were good because they were student focused and he really
got a chance to have a lot of experiences directly with the teachers yeah Latin
also was a book lecture oh I didn't know that at the time yeah we have a
Latin book collection did you work while you were in school yeah a sum the
NRTC program kept kept pretty busy but also later on helped by grading
papers and and that sort of thing for both the math department and the physics
department and that was a small amount of money but it actually helped but
primarily and then being grading papers is acting as sort of an assistant to
some professor you know and that sort of thing I didn't you know working a
restaurant or any that sort of thing well and when you were studying physics
especially I'm interested in knowing about the technologies that were
important to students at that point well we we had you know the technology of the
fifties in the early sixties right and so there were there were a lot of
old hula packer and tectonics measuring equipment that sort of thing and
the optic stuff was you know all the classical optics material and a lot of
that's probably still still the same because things like optics haven't the
introduction of the laser some of that technology haven't changed that much so
the lenses and that sort of thing you know probably the same knowledge as a
word that were then and they had I think while equipped laboratories and for
the time and it was it was good yeah I'm always interested in knowing about
the era before computers and computers we know anyway yeah well there was none
of that then the university had a computer then and it was
I started to take a computer course was I always thought this was sort of funny
and I showed up in this class and turns out most the other people already knew
what they were doing and you know and so the professor was talking to them
somebody like me was just out the lunch eventually I just quit the course
you know they need you to tell you where the computer was and how you did
anything they just started talking about a bunch of stuff that they were you know
more advanced it wasn't an introductory course at all which is what it was a
ledge to be and so it was it was sort of a bad experience quite frankly my
introduction to computers and they had something to say at that time I have
no idea what it was I never personally sought because I got out of the
business and then really get started into computers till later in graduate
school in very late in graduate school and then I became a talk for a few
years in Alabama we started automating some some of our equipment then but it
was still back in those those they're like in the 60s it was still calotypes not
sort of console it was a modems and very slow I mean people just wouldn't
recognize it now they wouldn't have the patience for it did you so you lived
in a dorm initially did you stay in the dorms all four years or no I didn't I
that I I didn't really like the dorms because they're sort of noisy and I'm
the sort of person I really have to have a sort of quiet and it's a little
solitude and the dorms are always very very noisy so the second year I in a
friend found an apartment over by the SAE house it's a church that's a church
said it won't be able to story house they rented out parts of it for students so
my friend and I moved in moved in there and at that time that wasn't that
wasn't really allowed I mean you had an undergraduate who was supposed to live
in student approved housing well this wasn't student approved housing we
just moved in there but eventually the dean caught up with us the dean of
man send us letters which we ignored and so forth but if it came over and not
on the door I don't remember his name but he was a very nice man and we talked
to him a while I told him I just you know we liked it there and it was and I was
getting good grades and being successful so it wasn't like we were and saved with
my roommate we're flunking out of school something it was actually being quite
successful as a living arrangement but so he blesses heart he went next door
who graduated student and his wife were living who I didn't know and got them to
sign that they would be your Procters or whatever they called it signed it that
they would keep an eye on us and so it became legitimate housing and I hadn't
realized that it was a process to turn a living situation to university
recognized but then that was the end of that never heard more about it and I stayed
there for the next two years and the third year we up I finally we lived a
roommate and I lived in a place called Kravals Towers or something like that
it was a high-rise building at that time in Portland area I mean then in the
Kravals area and that was that was that was fine too but that first one was a
sophomore when we ran into the dean that that's having a little concern but
you know I was trying to do what I thought was best for me and turned out fine
with that point this is still true to some degree but at that point the
Greek system was very big on campus and I'm wondering what it was like to
not be part of that to have try to have a social life but not necessarily
the engage with the Greek system we need you to engage with it. Not much I had
some friends over in fraternity in fact I met some of the fellows that lived
across the street at the SAE house and they were all fine we got long fine
there's no problems and we since I had been doing a double major in
healthful so working I didn't have a lot of time for socializing and I'm not
in most days I didn't think much of party and carrying on I like
I emphasize I liked it quite so I could get my work done so I never really
thought about that the fraternities and they were a little more expensive too I
think to live because by sharing an apartment the rim was relatively small
another kind of shared the rent and you did a lot of cooking in this food
preparation and it was really fairly inexpensive I would I would budget about
a thousand dollars maybe eleven hundred dollars a year to go to work in
state and with a little judicious spending and care you could make almost
out of mountain in a summary the working on the farms or plywood mill or a
sawmill or something like that nature and so you could quite easily work your
way through school of course I had a scholarship through the first two and a
half years that paid the tuition and I think they gave us $50 a month for
living to as part of that Navy program so it was you know small stipend and so
the financial aspects of going to college in the in the in the 60s and so
earlier two were just not burdensome almost anybody with a will could could
go to any school that they wanted whether it was you know Oregon University of
Oregon or Oregon State or you know Southern Oregon College in any school because
you could work your way fairly straightforward now I think that's not quite
probable likely not possible did you have any major extracurricular activities
that you did during during college not much except the that play you know
tennis and things like this with with friends but I didn't during a lot of
clubs or anything of that nature because you know it's pretty busy and focus on
my my activities but a lot of friends we did think would often you know have
your Friday night out at the bar down there the peacock whatever is one was
bars down there and have a good time and that was it but I didn't join I didn't
during a lot of clubs or anything of that nature to any particular hangout
besides the peacock not really but of course everybody you know would have a few
beers on their own strictly if you got away to get it even though it's not
not that legal in my respect but the students as always are
inner pricing and was never a problem why don't I ask you about a few events
that happened at Oregon State when you were there the first one in 1961
Oregon State College became Oregon State University that made much of an
impact on you to be memory of that I have remember and the people there
thought it was a big deal I remember everybody being enthused about it because I
guess and a lot of people's minds the the name university has more prestige
and meaning than college and I guess it does personally at that time I I
didn't care that much as I recall because you know I had known as Oregon State
College OSC you know I was a high plus where I applied it didn't mean a lot to me
in terms of a bit of things because whether degree whether your degree said
Oregon State College or State University to me it didn't mean very much but
you know to some people I and I can understand it it did mean a lot to them
because I think in the in the academic hierarchy being called a university is
more meaningful than you know college it's it's more restricted term doesn't
imply the research and graduate programs and so forth that you you think of
in terms of the university and I think that was that was the goal of course in
October of 1962 is the Columbus Day Storm you remember that vaguely yeah and you
know it's a bad storm and and I didn't affect me in any way you know
directly I mean we didn't lose any of our home or any of that nature either in
privilege or like the parents rose we didn't have any problems and so I did
it didn't drastically drastically affect me in any way I don't get it you're a
big football fan but Terry Baker won the highest trophy in 1962 as well do you
remember much hoopla or surrounding that oh yeah there was a lot of hoopla and he
was a great athlete because he was a he started the best school the best school
as well and yeah I didn't know in person of course but he was he was famous in
his own time and I used to go to football games and they I think the students got
in you know freer or or almost nothing if there was it was a game you know
it's not otherwise engaged I try to get down to watch right I enjoy football
it's the one sport I do care for right not really a basketball or baseball fan
that much but I do like football and so I go some of the games but in all the
hoopla associated with it so I enjoy the athletic teams well what was your
sense of corralis at the time that somewhat smaller place and it is now
obviously any particular relationship with the town I like corbalis it was
the the people were friendly and nice and there there wasn't a crime to speak
of and you know I'd read my bicycle outside in my house or the apartment where I
lived I never had a stolen and this sort of thing and never had a stolen from
the building or anything like that so yeah I enjoy I have no negative memories of
it at all of course the lovely campus I always thought Oregon State had a truly
lovely campus in the spring when everything's in bloom and the landscaping is
it's really really nice and in those days they didn't have all those cut and
streets all the streets went through and you didn't have all the limited access
that you have now and but parking was critical I mean it was not easy when I
I lived my part I got an apartment system problem with that in the dorm you
had to park way down there by pass the tennis courts by the call seam and walk
across the fields and so forth there was no parking close by so it was
inconvenient for some of the cars in those days but yeah it was I like I like
corbalis it's a lovely little town and it's certainly a nicer place to live
than what I ended up going to grad school in South Chicago I mean night and day
I'm sure yeah I'm sure of that well that brings us to the sort of the next
section of your life you graduated in 1964 from Oregon State how did you
decide what you're going to do next well I had decided back in my junior year
when I got out of the Navy that out of the NROTC program that I wanted to go on
to get a degree of PhD in physics and do research and work at research
last but I really liked that and so I applied to graduate school and I was
interested in that after getting away from the West Coast so I applied to the
University of Chicago and a couple schools out of West here I remember I
Berkeley and University of Washington and I got accepted by the University of
Chicago and they offered me a research fellowship and an assistantship so that
covered the education of course they paid the tuition to so I was able to go
to the University of Chicago you know actually by the time I finished I was saved up
a little money in fact that's where I met my wife too as a Chicago in 1966 so
it was it was an employee that chose Chicago's one of the reasons it's a good
school and the financial aid package was very generous I thought and it was a
different part of the country it was interesting to move out to another part
of the country what's certainly different it was a real lesson to me never
having been to Chicago I didn't interview the school or anything like that I got
accepted and I had an old 57 Dodge station wagon at the time I loaded up all
my stuff and drove across Montana and on down into Chicago and right there
and made one or you know I was going to survive because it's a very different
environment yeah tell me about that transition you're living in a major city living
in a I have a rough part of a major city yeah it was the South
Chicago was in a transition from a widely white Polish Irish community to
primarily black or African American and then there was all those problems
associated with that in terms of you know the cultural clashes and so you
would see that frequently and a lot of you know racism on on both sides
particularly as as as the population and population profile demographic
change in these neighborhoods there was a lot of trouble in people's minds
anyhow and so it was it was an interesting the interesting things of course
something you'd not exposed to an organ at all you never had the idea and so
was it from a town like Corvallis where there's very few minorities at
least at that time go to Chicago or in South Chicago you know somebody like me
a white person was a minority and it was it was a real experience and it gives
you perspective on how minorities in this country the kinds of perceptions
they must have and some of their some of their perplexions I guess what
causes trouble and anxieties but it's a it's a good lesson I think for
everybody yeah well the university you're into it was a world-class
university in the University of Chicago very high-powered in the sciences tell me
a little bit about that atmosphere that you you came into at that point it was
it was it was it was very competitive I mean the students were all you know
you know very very bright I remember the chairman told me that everybody
in the class had GRE scores and the 98 percentile above and and they were all
really really successful successful students it was very competitive fortunately
I my background at Oregon State sort of mean good said I had no problems with
the academics and work at that Chicago and it went well and made the normal
course of events and graduated in six seven years with a PhD it was a
typical time for physics in those days at Chicago I think it's some of the
other majors take it was less time but so I graduated in the early 1970
I want to ask you about a couple people that were there I believe when you
were there that are big names the first is an Indian fellow Superb onion
Chandra Shikar absolutely he's a great professor I had him for a couple of
classes actually and statistical physics and and atomic molecular physics quantum
mechanics advanced quantum mechanics and he was a brilliant teacher and he would
come in and just start his lecture and hit perfect handwriting on the board
is this was the days of chalkboards none of this stuff and no overhead
projections thing that sort of thing with the classical blackboards we cite them
up and down fill up a room with that and he would start precisely on time and
then since and finish precisely on time noise with a coherent message and as
last few minutes would be a summary and then you could write all the summaries
down on your notes and then you'd you'd have the important elements of
the conversation and the talk so he's a brilliant professor really a nice
person a chemist Robert Mulligan won the Nobel Prize in 1966 while you were
there do you remember that yes and I knew a new Robert Mulligan he was in the
same building as well I did my research and I would see him frequently he was a
he was an interesting man a brilliant brilliant chemist physicist and a
particular physics and a whole bunch of students and then post-docs he had a
large enterprise in those days doing spectroscopes being theoretical
theoretical physics and so on but he was a real quiet man and all he was
already old by the time I got to know him and I didn't have any classes from him
but he didn't teach much he was all just a hundred percent research and of course
traveling a lot because he was a world famous but he had a dozens of people
working in his laboratories and then a Ryerson Hall at the University of
Cognizatives well it sounds like a tremendously enriching environment I'm
do you tell me about this or the progression of your of your academic courses
there your research time yeah I work I had my for shoot up there and then the
fall of 64 I was assigned to work for a professor Mark Ingraham who did
mass spectrometry and chemical physics and various sorts of
instrumentations look at properties of the top of the molecular systems and I
worked in his lab as a research assistant for the first couple years and in
Chicago they had you had to take regular take physics courses and then think of
that nature as well as preparing for what they call an entrance exam or the
the candidate exam you usually took that at the start of your in the fall of
your second year that was a very very hard test the qualifier and so the first
year graduate students would spend huge amounts of time studying old tests and
problems because it was a three-day test you know with all problems I mean it
was none of this motor will guess that was all problems to solve and in all
areas of physics and so you had to be well prepared and so on fortunately I
passed that the first time through and I was able to get my research started and
that was a also a test which a lot of a lot of people didn't make it the first
time they'd have to take away six months or year and take it again and then
a lot that some people just left it was so daunting that they just left but
that's like a lot of universities have those sort of qualified exams and it's
it's a it's a hurdle at all all people studying for an advanced degree have to
overcome but it was it was taxing it occupied each month your time and you
just study it and then to learn the material to pass those exams it was rewarding
because there's a focus of your attention and you really did learn a lot I mean
if you take the right attitude so it has been a very very beneficial process as
far as I can see so I'm in favor of difficult exams I think that it focuses
on his attention and and and enables you to really really do learn some
words and things well then I worked up if I passed this qualifier exam then you
could start a PhD program you couldn't formally start you pass that qualifier
so you have to find some professor who would take you on and then have some
research project that you wanted to do and I chose to stay with the guy who
worked as a research assistant because I was interested in the physics and
then the programs that he had and he also is a really nice generous man and he
had a you know five or six graduate students have a couple post-docs and it
was a it was a good learning environment so I elected to stay there and worked on
some problems in in photorodization we had machines that would generate vacuum
ultraviolet radiation and and use that radiation with monocromers dispersate and
use that use that radiation to study atomic and molecular systems you know
ionize them and use the mass spectrometer or spectrometer depending on to
analyze those reaction products from the ionization process and it's the
study things like cross sections and so forth for for
a reaction photon atom and molecule reactions and my work that did was to look
at ionization processes in rare earth elements the lanthanides so things like
eropium and eterbium erbium and things of that nature we generated ovens made
they're all metals at room temperature so you have to make a oven and in
generate a atomic beam all this is in vacuum of course the generator beam of
those and intersect that beam with the with the light beam and and to ionization
process you start knocking off electrons and you can monitor then the ion
products as a function of wavelength of the light and determine its
ionization potential so we measured some of the ionization processes of these
rare earth elements which hadn't been done because it was prior to this
difficult subsequent people did a lot of spectroscopy others and did much
got much more accurate results but it's those kind of experiments and it's
sort of a lot of fun you had to build learn how to build ovens a little high
temperature ovens and intersect that with all in the vacuum system and
intersect that with the light beam and get the mass of a comma which is a
relatively large instrument to measure the ion products and we also did some
work with organic molecules which are a lot easier you just let them they
vaporize and you can get a molecular beam fairly straightforward from
what's the organic molecule and study their processes and look at their
dissociation processes as well so we did studies of various kinds of molecules
that we would look at their ionization as well as dissociation processes how
independent were you in in developing these topics was it something where you
you went to your mentor with this idea or was it kind of the way around now
what you had to end with with professor England you had to develop your own
copy and then convince him that this was something to do and even support
and that's what I did I was interested in the these rare earth because there
was some there was some interest in the scientific community about some of
their ionization properties and also some of the internal energy properties of
some of the organic molecules we studied people were interested in their internal
processes and then measuring their their energies if you will and because the
internal energies of these molecules determine how they combine with others
and so on and so there was interest in and getting things called heats of
formation of molecule ions and so forth that we did some studies on systems
who were of interest for other kinds of chemistry because that told you energy
balances in these ion molecule reactions so we were engaged in that kind of
research using these four ionization tools and those days that the four
ionization studies was hard because you had to have laboratory light sources so
these would be discharges pulse discharges with a high electrical pulse in a
in a capillary tube filled with a rare gas usually or hydrogen in some cases
and like helium and then you generate the helium would get excited and
generate molecular helium which would then dissociate because helium was an
inner gas it doesn't form a molecule except in excited states and that
dissociation process is a mature radiation and the far old to violet so we'd use
that radiation and dispersal with the monocrominern and study these atoms and
then the ion molecules as well but subsequent you know by the time I left
graduate school and in the late 60s and it's certainly now and 70s on the
development of synchrotron radiation and also laser sources of the totally
surplated that to do what we did in those days now you go to synchrotron
most likely it would be fairly straightforward but it was it was hard that in
those days because of the the technology available you're limited to laboratory
light sources now there's the synchrotron radiation sources throughout the
world in fact that one worked at the National Institute of Standards and
Technology I was the reason they had a small synchrotron radiation source at
the institute and we use that for atomic and like for physics studies the same
kinds of basic technologies as I use in graduate school instead of having
these discharge light sources like a neon bulb if you will you have these big
big machines that generated radiation from synchrotron radiation but
as far as graduate school goes you had to you had the divisional projects and
then you had to publish and then Chicago had a requirement at that time that
your thesis had to be published in the peer reviewed literature so I had to
prepare an article for the journal chemical physics and then once that was
accepted that was and that was then you escaped the the rigors of half to
write a formal thesis that the paper that you wrote got accepted in a peer
reviewed journal was was basic your thesis you just bound that and and that
was it and you were not have to write one of these tedious 300 paid
thesis or something like some some places required I thought it was a good idea
because if you stop thinking about that's what you want your researchers to do
is be able to publish in the peer reviewed literature so that that's I thought
that was always a clever and sensible criteria and so something you had to achieve
but at least as graduate student you're guaranteed at least having one
publication if you're going to get your degree. Were there any folks within the
department that emerged as being important to you rememberable besides Ingram?
Oh yeah I had some classes from a famous scientist Greg Revenso and he was
he was a very very good teacher of a no-world gentleman like a swisher German
and he was one of the founders of the quantum vector dynamics back in the
40s and he was a he was a professor at Chicago at that time and also met I
learned a lot from the technical staff in the physics department of those
days they had a wonderful electronic engineer that's I worked with
developing building equipment and electronics equipment they had some
wonderful people in a machine shop because we had to make our own equipment we
didn't you didn't go to a catalog and buy a a mass spectrometer or a monocromber
you made it yourself and so I learned machining techniques and also got to be
a fairly good heliarch welder because we'd weld that the chambers together
the vacuum chambers together and that sort of thing and the guys in the shop would
teach you to do all that stuff and so I thought it was fascinating I got to do
all kinds of things that you know got paid for as a student that I really enjoyed
doing it was it was it was a wonderful experience how the years of Chicago were
just really in my mind really really very good and additionally getting a
family started and so on it was a wonderful learning experience did you do any
teaching uh case me and I would teach a course but not for undergrad I teach
some courses and people preparing for the basic exam or the qualifying exam
and assist assistant in some of the graduate courses but I never I was never
reached a teaching assistantship and in the sense of teaching the undergraduate courses
and so forth I was I avoided that and I was able to have a research assistantship
or they were in the lab and never never got so much involved on the teaching
side tell me about meeting Ruth 1966 that that was an interesting story we I was
driving out to go to my sister's wedding and she I had I was going to bring an
Indian friend of mine guy from India a menon was his name and he was going to
ride with me we were going to share expenses well he was a far tougher business man
than I was and he determined since I had that it was on the Dodge station
way of the time there was room for others he went around I'm being
honest to me and solicited other riders to go parts of the trip one guy came
all the way to Eugene I dropped him off on Eugene and but the Ruth rode with us
with a friend to Cheyenne Wyoming and we let him off there and I had a men
and had some financial reasons I don't know what it was and and so I got to be
a courier of people across the country to go on this trip but the minute
figure I had a minute figure he saved himself a lot of money I didn't expect
so that's how I met Ruth and I got back to Chicago right so I've seen her
turned out she lived in a place where I lived in an international house in
Chicago so we got together in Michigan Mary and she was a student I mean she's
an undergraduate at the time and you said you started a family yeah and a daughter
was born there her son was born there too in Chicago hospitals so what was
that like being a family man and a student at the same time it worked out pretty
well fortunately my wife is real capable and she she worked at some two at a
correspondence school they're called the American school it was in fact it was
a block away from our apartment where we left and so she could go get papers
and grade papers and work on these correspondence courses and that turned out a
source of income and and do that at home she didn't have to leave it in so the
child was was was washed at home and we lived in student housing that was right on
campus and fairly close so that worked out well well you were in Chicago during
turbulent times the 68th Democratic Convention as well known as being sort of
an iconic moment for that time period in that location you have any
memories of it was awful everybody's bad behavior contributed to a really
awful event I mean nothing no one can be proud of those days in my mind I mean
the protesters are out of line but then in the Chicago case the police's
response were totally out of line and I think it was characterized as a police
riot and I think that's about right now I'm a pretty conservative fellow but I
mean the Chicago cops were just we're just not the best I hope they've changed
over the years but you know I got shaken down twice in my in my years in
Chicago because I had an out-of-state plate license plate by cops you want to
drive for letting me off it was it was not pleasant I mean it did but that's
the way it was not all cops obviously but it was a corruption and they were not
nice not nice to the protesters in those days in fact I was I never went
up town to the to the world the convention was but I was just walking back
from the lab one night and there's some cop cars patrolling down there by the
university looking for students to to harass and I had to they you know
well they were there's a cop a follow-up but I can tell it was a cop by their
plane clothesmen and they were thinking about harassing me they're
dragging by me as I was walking and really checking me out I could tell
that they were they were not thinking good thoughts they they were down in the
Southside and I suspect they wanted to get it on the action the comments were
having downtown and no I didn't like that that the Chicago cops at that time
I had to not a lot of respect for them because of my personal experiences
which may work in in family probably not a lot of free time but I'm wondering if
there's anything about Chicago that made a big impact on you in sort of a
social or cultural way there's a lot of cultural activities and as a student you
don't have a lot of money but there are a lot of inexpensive things to do
well the University of Chicago is not far from Lake Michigan and so you can you
can just walk down to the lake and have some beaches and so forth there was a
the Chicago Museum of the Side Industry was very close to the campus and that was
a wonderful museum and we'd go there frequently and they had forest
preserves in the outskirts of Chicago that were you know big parks and and so
Ruth and I and would spend time there on the picnic in the summer so you
wouldn't go out there in the Chicago winter but it's a couple of a couple of
guys I worked with in the machinists and the case of go fishing and do
something of that nature too so it's an interesting environment Chicago it's
very different from here and it was a real cultural shock the big thing
the Y-57 Dodge and I drove out had a you know it was an organ car right and so
the tires were bald and the battery was ancient and as soon as I get cold in
November car wouldn't start and the first time I got a little snow in the
street you couldn't go anywhere because the tires I had no tread and of course
I had a light windbreak kind of jacket and it got cold and so that
November December was a hectic time I had to get the car up so I would run in
in the in the winter time and go on the roads as well as get some clothes that
were appropriate for you know that 10 degree environment when the wind's
howling so that was a real real real shocker in my first quarter I was living
in Chicago I was living in an apartment about 20 or 30 blocks from from what
the university was so I had to drive back and forth to school and I soon
rectified that I got a room at the international house for the second three
quarters that first year and I was able to walk back and forth to campus
because driving in the in the winters with an older car is not the best way
to get around it was terribly inconvenient and also parking problems and
cities it was a bad move and of course I hadn't realized that my first
applied to Chicago had been smart to range housing in advance I think it was
like pervallas you could just find an apartment you know that's a big city
fight it wasn't the case the apartment the living arrangements were a little
scarce and it was so it took me a few days actually when I arrived there I'd
stay in a hotel or someplace for a few days and I'd like to find an apartment
it was a quite far actually far from the university interesting learning
experience well yeah sort of the continuing topic of cultural shifts he'd
finished up in 1971 Chicago and went to Alabama tell me about that well I thought
I wanted to be a teaching profession and a friend of mine a former graduate
student who graduated went to the University of Alabama and got a pretty good
grant to get his research set up and and so they recruited me as well to come
down and get a research project started I interviewed with them and also with
a couple companies and decided I was going to be interviewed with a
sanded oil as it's called s or something and those days out in New Jersey
and they offered me a job as well but it had been an area in New Jersey I didn't
think much of it besides I wanted to get teaching a goal so I took a job as
an assistant professor at the University of Alabama so we lived in Tuscanos, Alabama
for 1970 to 78 years I guess it was and then I went on sabbatical leave at the
Bureau standards that was called in Maryland and then they offered me a job
and I decided that whether it be at the National Bureau standards rather than
back teaching and the research opportunities were far better it was a it was a
struggle at you know Alabama is a good school it's like in the other state
school but it's in those days it was hard to raise money and we thought it
difficult to raise money you know from the foundations and so forth and and
Alabama to get our research started we raised some we were fairly successful
let's turn to my Andrew Jason and I there were insurance and facilities there
but it was very very difficult he spent a lot of time just trying to raise
money and then so on and also the teaching mode was fairly heavy compared to
most universities it was two courses you had to have six contact hours a quarter
and didn't leave a lot of time for very research you just had to be in there
all hours of the day and night so it was not the best research environment of
course the University of Chicago was a graduate student that professors taught one
course two out of the three quarters one quarter they taught nothing I mean
they didn't have any teaching obligations so I mean there's a big difference
between the research universities in Europe and your average state
University I might just still that way most state universities that professors
will have at least two courses and that's very time consuming and so the at
the Bureau standards was on sabbatical leave versus no teaching and they were
fairly well funded compared to what it was at the Alabama and it was funded
directly by the government for government programs and so eventually I
got in a position we got to raise a lot of money you know because NBS events
the government organization we did do work for other government agencies and so
we did had programs at NASA and no department of defense supported so I raised
a lot we raised a lot of money from those agencies but for you know we'll be
applying programs rather than you know trying some fundamental research program
like at National Science Foundation so it was a very different environment I
actually sort of liked a lot better yeah so was the the project the research
topic in Alabama was that made mostly an extension of what you had been doing in
Chicago yeah so I built a smaller version of what we had in Chicago and we were
going to do do small work on on rare earth some got started on that and then
they'll small organic molecules and I did just gotten that project started
when I went on sabbatical leave and the reason I went on sabbatical leave was a
somebody gave it a donation or some money came up somehow they're going to
totally renovate the physics building everybody's going to have to move out all
the labs are going to be closed down so I said well what other than to sit here
for a year I had an offer had had an offer to go to to Maryland and the
National Bureau standards to work with a team there in the same kind of work
a photo organization studies and so I said well I'll just take a sabbatical
leave it's I want to work for them and you know just as a sabbatical leave
at the go standards and then that first year I still be paid by by Alabama and
and the National Bureau standards sent them some money to you know to pay for my
time it's called the Intergovernmental Personnel Act appointee and so I spent
the first year there then I was going to go back we're going to go back to
Alabama because we liked it that we had a nice house we'd build a nice house and
so forth but they they decided they didn't get done with the renovation things
bug on so they're going to be out a second year so I they had asked me if I
could stay a second year at the Bureau standards I said okay so it worked out
good then sometimes during the second year early in the second year they offered
me up a staff position at the Bureau standards which was actually doubled my
salary and then and it was a we're involved in a research program I really liked
and really had tied national international profile and worked with about a
really some really top people and it was all research and there was no there's
no teaching and no committees and none of this not a lot of fundraising in those
days so it was a real opportunity I thought and so I elected to stay at the
Bureau standards and so we just never went back to Alabama but that was not the
intention when we first went to the Gatedsburg Maryland for the Bureau standards
located what was your impression of the South when you were there I like
that it was the weather's awful I mean that's I never got used to that they
you know it starts in in May the hot humanity and you know it'll be in the
90s and you would you know by human I mean 90% humanity not people here get
off site if it's 40% humanity but I mean it would be very very human and it's
hard to get used to I never really did of course everything in your house your
carvings air condition you turn that air conditioning on and layman like I say
you're something by June and it would just be on until October I mean it was to
me it was very different now the natives people growing up in that they they
don't seem to bother but they you know you have become accustomed to a bite I
never really climatized to that hot email just that's the only thing I did
like about the people were nice Tuscaloosa is a loving little town it's no
say it was a smaller town bigger than Corvallis but it was a total college town
basic but and of course now it's a lot bigger they put a car factory Mercedes
one of those companies put a assembly plant there in Alabama that's not far
away so it's a lot of industrialization so it's a changed environment just
like a lot of college how about the culture of the area it was it was very
different I mean you know you normally think of it south as being real racist
well they they had this the old vestiges of segregation but it was to me it was
less harsh in those terms you know what I used to see in Chicago it was really
ugly in my mind in fact the first department I rented the guy says I'll give you
real good deal because I want a white guy live in here boy oh I didn't I had no
idea what the customer I'll take the deal because I need a place to say
this is good you know I hadn't arranged the housing but they were they were
they were there was definite racism and you could observe it you'd see some of
that in Alabama but not to the extent the race it seemed more harmonious to me
than the racial relations in Chicago the events of the blacks and the whites and
and then South now that other people probably have a different perspective I
know but I mean I didn't I didn't see the harshness that I would and they'll
work the things expressed that I saw in Chicago but just one man's take I
think other people I think I'll probably very different take on well one thing I'm
sure that was an inescapable while you were there was was called football oh yeah
they have one three national championships during your time bearbrain is the
coach yeah it was they take football real seriously in the South I mean the
average were going I mean they just live and die and then you know place like
Texas too I mean just and Mississippi Louisiana all of that says it is the sport
and they then they really take it take it seriously and and Alabama has this
constant feud with Auburn which is sort of Auburn sort of the quote of
Oregon State it's a it's a land crack school I think and Auburn because it's
in in the city of Auburn but there's a fierce rivalry and it's been going off
for years and years and they and they and it comes apart of the culture you can
people that don't go to the schools you know they're an Auburn and Alabama fan
and you know they can be a mill worker whatever you know I know they'll have
these for unknown reasons I see some of that in Oregon but nice it's not like
it's just pronouns but they do they do take football seriously and bear
Bryant was a really re-burred revered person I mean he had a lot of
clop I think for sure well you mentioned sabbatical and you started up
full-time at the National Bureau of Standards in 1980 so I guess you can
tell me a little bit about moving to the DC area and settling in and then your
first position a physicist in the radiations physics division yeah I was I
liked I liked it the climate Maryland is a little better you get you get cold
winners in Maryland so you get more diversity it's an Alabama it's hot most
of the time even all around but Maryland it's it she wouldn't hot in the
summertime which it cools down the fall on the winter you'll get snow and
so on so we first year we lived in an apartment and neither my wife and our
kids were like that so we bought a house after I was offered a job and bought a
house and lived in the same place I think from 1980 on and so I I kind of
like it it's a Washington DC area is a culturally diverse and very
very interesting region it's Civil War battlefields you know Gettysburg
Gettitum will run all those are hour so drive away from where we lived in
Gettysburg and those are all very interesting and well done by the National Park
Service in terms of historical presentations I really enjoyed that we enjoyed
the museums downtown the specific museums are just simply the best there is
and and that's that's all free and you know from where we were 30 minutes away
and take the train down now they put a subway system in and we live close to
the terminals of this one subway lines we could easily beat the end down if you
wanted so the cultural cultural things are immense and we would get season
tickets to the to some orchestra arrangements at the Kennedy Center and that
was that was always great crowded but great I mean it's as traffic is awful
downtown Washington but it was a it was a nice place to live I enjoyed the
experience a great deal and you know there was a the
negocytes is the weather and it's also very very crowded the roads the Washington
Bellway it's it's truly awful and the road we were not too far from the
interstate 270 which runs out of north of sort of northwest out of Washington
and that it's a missing busy road because all the commuter traffic back
forth to DC and from the Maryland suburbs at the work downtown and it's 14
lanes in places you know seven lanes each way with feet or just it's just
awful and you get on out of each the bumper to bumper all those lanes and
rush hour if he off rush hour is busy we would sometimes we bought a boat that
we kept over on the chest beacon even on a Saturday morning getting over to the
Chesapeake which is anapolis near anapolis was it should have been easy you know
hour hour and a half drive sometimes it lasts a lot longer because it's just
traffic on Saturday morning so it's a very very crowded that's one of the reasons
when we're required we we're not gonna live in in the DC suburbs just ended up
out here instead in Oregon but I think I was in decision we both are really glad
we made mainly the living conditions I mean the coastal activities that you
know and the things in the DC suburbs are really superb but the crowdedness
and the weather are really contrary to my particular life so some people
like it of course you know not what I like so we enjoy the weather and the
environment here much better we'll tell you about the prevention of your work
I was first hired at I was post-talking either not really post-talking
though I was for working as a guest scientist there the first year of our
civil professor at Alabama I worked in a laboratory with a guy named Henry
Rosenstock and Roger Stockbauer were very well known in in chemical
physics for doing in term structures of molecules they're the energetics of
molecules so we worked with some techniques using called threshold photoelectron
spectroscopy studying a molecular process as small molecules then at that
first year also they were getting started on the synchrotron facade and this
the NEMBS has a small electron synchrotron which generates light
ultraviolet light they were getting a project started using synchrotron
radiation for photoelectrospectroscopy so I joined along with Roger Stockbauer
and a team from Argon Joe Deemer and his team at Argon National Laboratory
built an electron spectrometer system that was able to angler resolve the
electrons coming off from an ionization process and atoms with many small
molecules so we built that system at first year I was there and then and then
that was another reason for me to stay a second year and then eventually take a
job because that apparatus was just coming into fruition in terms of this
productivity so we were able to do some really really really interesting things
and new kinds of studies using synchrotron radiation and this electron spectrometer
doing angle resolved photoelectronization studies it was some of the first of
that type in the world and it was very well received you know in this
community so we did that and then build a successively built new instruments in
terms of for photoelectron spectroscopy and angle resolved and
participated and else participated in a few other kinds of experience and so
the laboratory experiments that I first got started on when we went there we
quit all that all together and track those labs were closed down to make up
all the photoelectronization had to work out that was done with the synchrotron
and that's where I was hired when they offered me a staff position was to work
on the the team of science is working on that they call it surf synchrotron
ultraviolet radiation facility at MPS and in 1980 you're 81 they changed the
name from MPS to NIST so it's the same organization with these
Congress in there infinite wisdom decided to change the name reflected a
little different mission I guess was the idea like changing Oregon State
College, Oregon State University that sort of thing and that nothing fundamentally
changed it's just after we do all the letterhead and door signs but it's
I worked in that operation for about five years as a as a research physicist in
the radiation physics division and with the pilot about a physics group under
working with the under the guy named Robert Matten who was in charge of the
synchrotron very well known optical person monoclonal design and so forth
so it was a wonderful experience working with the scientists there and the
other nice nice thing about NIST I'll call it that that's his name now is
that it's in Washington DC area so you get a continual tour touring of a
really well known scientist from throughout the world this is one thing I missed
in in Alabama you know you have to really work out to get to Tuscaloosa but
everybody comes through Washington DC and they would visit NIST in the
those days and we also collaborated with a team of scientists on these
photon works from from from England and John West from Darsbury laboratory in
England key coddling from a Reading University in England another people in our
programs and in fact I would then go to to England and work on on the
on the sycrotron facility at Darsbury in the United Kingdom and the later
stages we transported over the instrumentation that we'd build it NIST
new flow electron spectroscopy we we we transported it to England this was a
big piece of equipment many tons and and transported to the Darsbury laboratory
and near up near Manchester Darsbury is a small town and in the side of the
performer and do some work over there as well with my English colleague so it was
a real nice collaboration between the Bureau standard and NIST and the and the
English Darsbury laboratory so of course they made good French movies so so
have to this day with the English colleague got spent some time in in other
sycrotron facilities in France and other places as well to visit it was a very
very rewarding time so I typically and a lot of travel and and interesting people
that was one of the nice things I really enjoyed about NIST was the depth of
the people we've worked with and so the best people from from all over the
world we had guests from France China you know Japan all over and come to work
in our laboratories and that was a extremely rewarding scientific time and so
I worked on those sycrotron race experiments until the mid 1980s 85 or 86
something like that then I was offered a job in another division as a group leader
there was a division that was having some personnel problems and and they had
a lot of difficulties and I was asked to take over a group that was they needed
some attention and they called the specter radiometry group I guess it was
the name of it so I became a group leader which is the law level management
physician at NIST and I think about 1986 something like that I don't know and
worked on that division it was called the radiometric physics division and it
was its job was to do all the optical measurements or most of the optical
measurements for this country of standards they did everything from standard light
bolts you know when you buy light bulb the store will have a aluminum rating on it
but we maintain those standards in the standard of the candle as well as optical
temperature measurements so we developed that division responsibilities to
maintain all those standards as well as to develop the technology to improve
the the standards so the worked a lot with industry to collaborate with industrial
partners to develop better measurement techniques to help product quality
and reliability on the assembly a lot of work with zero off companies like
Kodak 3M that they do have a lot of optical
optical measurement problems for example 3M makes a lot of white paper and
things like that they should need reflective standards and how you measure all
that and so on I spent time with helping Kodak develop color of colored
measuring processes and optical processes for property making and measuring
film they had a lot a lot of interest and that in those days those are the film
days the whole technology has changed but then on LEDs and other kinds of sources
light sources that became available we had to develop the technology to
properly characterize those and imagine because they there are a little
different little different needs in your incandescent bulbs and
fluorescent bulbs and so our division worked with industry to develop the
right strategy to making reliable and consistent measurements and it came
industry standards in for how you measure an LEDs property and so on so
that's the job that division I've actually became the division chief of that
division I remember when that was and then
ladies early 90s and that's why I retired in 2007 was this chief of the
changes name and optical technology division since I've blessed the
subsequent changes name again there's been another reorganization but it's
basically the same division now called sensor science division or something of
that nature so I was able to then be in charge of all these measurement techniques
and develop develop develop work for other government agencies and that was
very rewarding I enjoyed that we had projects back in the mid-80s
effect was one of my first jobs as a group leader in spectoradiometry the
defense department was having problems characterizing very low level
infrared sensors that are used for satellite purposes and very
the national security program and they had to be sensors that were
calibrated at very very low temperatures because they were sensors that look
at the background of space looking at missile threat that sort of thing and so
they would operate very low temperatures that had to be calibrated and make
for measurement experiments to make sure they were seen what they told you they
were seen and that we developed techniques to calibrate things that you know
five degrees Kelvin just a little above absolute zero very very low
temperatures and called a low background infrared calibration so if that was a
real challenge technically and that that's facility still and in place being
used to to characterize a very low level background as signals that sensor
systems primarily do the occasionally NASA and other government agencies have
needs for characterizing very low low background sources things are going to
operate the space primarily so that was a fun project and and develop new
technology and capabilities for the Department of Defense and they of course would
pay for the Department of Defense of Payness for doing this work and so we
raised on a lot of projects for NOAA and NASA for the support that's
where the optical did division supporting satellite technology you see these
pictures of the color pictures of the earth you see you see pictures of the
oceans where they they're using cameras from on spacecraft to measure ocean
properties all those cameras and then and devices have to be calibrated their
spectrary armors system basically flying around the space looking at the
spectral content of light coming back from the earth from the surface
reflected and that tells you about the the properties of the vegetation in the
case the oceans the plankton and then in the in the carbon content of the ocean
so we work with a NASA developed calibration strategies to calibrate the
satellites and then involves building calibration systems for the satellites
before they are launched and then trying to build systems so they can
verify their operational and flight and that tells us for example the satellite
looking at standard sources in fact there's a we have one of the big projects
was to have a there's a buoy system out near and not Lenin and Hawaiian islands
that measures the light coming out of the ocean they call it the upwelling
radiance of the ocean so it's reflected light from the sun going back up and
that's what the spacecraft will see you see you'll see the light coming off the
ocean so that's measured out in Hawaii so the spacecraft will have a and it'll
fly over and give them a simultaneously measurement we can tell them what it is at
the Earth's surface of the water surface if you will and the satellite then can
check its calibration and that's been an ongoing project in fact I'm still
consulting some on that particular project but we have other projects to
develop in other projects developing calibration procedures and measurement
procedures a whole range of sensor systems for the for the no one asks the
projects as well as the defense department another another agencies that have
a secure program so they have the rice-fiscated sensor systems we work with
them on that as well let's see I or whatever you know they have a center
programs and we were a government agency that would help work with them to
to develop their central measurement capabilities but as I listen to you
describe this said a couple things occurred I mean everyone it sounds like there's
a pretty big shift when you when you switch gears to the radiation
physics division or to that sorry the great spectral radio on the
spectral radio on the tree group from doing sort of this more fundamental
research you're doing before to this the standard of the big shift from a
fundamental research to applied research but the underlying theme was it was
all light measuring and manipulation controlling light and sick
coroneration using light as a source so you have to build monocromers and
build detectors of radiological radiation and so on so and then in
radiometry the concentration is not on the use of the light but of measuring
the light and characterizing you see and characterizing the sensors so that
someone else can you know quickly determine what they're measuring and in the
case the satellites what they want to know is what the what the the radiation is
a one way that compared to another and the one or that pretty accurately so
that those ratios those wavelengths will tell you for example the plankton
concentration and so it's it's all optics of some sort or the
electromagnetic radiation but it's a different emphasis you have to write the
radiometry division was very applied on the measurement and the measurement
technology and development of sources as well as the characterization of
these things whereas the previously the sick coroneration resources was the
fundamental driver was trying to understand some basic features of the
atomic collector of physics you know how molecules are nice and dissociate so
on it's also the application of science to a very wide variety of projects
some of which apparently involve some national security implications must
develop a tremendous fun yeah it is and very diverse I mean and we had
colleagues at our labs in Boulder there was a whole group of divisions it was
just concentrated on developing techniques for measuring laser and laser power
and that was you know we collaborate them too it was fascinating and so it was
a real learning experience and it was also a lot of fun and you know that's the
highest level and you're the best people doing this anywhere I think our
organization had you know in terms of national lives it was probably you know
the one of the premier national labs and in the world in terms of the quality of
its research and calibration and development so it was a really you know
really a lot of fun and it was a very rewarding and intellectually I mean
and again it's the people I mean these are the best for these were the best
people in these fields in anywhere so it's a very enjoyable time it's a job
that I hope everybody can get I mean a job in a sense that you go to work and
you really love it and you don't try to avoid working on it that's fun to be
there so I really feel fortunate in that regard to have got myself into
a career where work was really fun it was financial rewarding but it was it was
enjoyable to do and not some people I'm doing you talked to there there was
discrepanel about the working I would never say that I truly enjoyed my
career in grad school at Oregon State I enjoyed being a student I enjoyed
graduate school and I enjoyed beating the national junior state of technology as
well
couldn't ask for any more with it yeah well what was what was your what was your
family up to while during the DC era DC years your wife and children yeah my wife
worked that she worked at several occupations she ran daycare at home for a
while but eventually she went back to the school to went to hop and John
Hopkins and got her a master's degree in counseling and then working in the
school systems there in Montgomery County for many years as a middle school
counselor and so on so she was able to retire from that when we left as a school
counselor my kids went both went to college in Maryland and they enjoyed that
my fact my son is still out in in there he lives and he said the
after college he wanted to be a cop he got on he's with the Fairfax County
police it's just across the river from Washington DC and he enjoys that a great
deal my daughter is a nurse and she lives out here in in Oregon City works for
Kaiser and in an important area
well I switch gears a little bit and ask you about books and book collecting
that's how we first became acquainted with one another and I'm interested in
remember that start how do you get into collecting collecting books I still
have my books from high school and a lot of them and probably a good portion of
my books from from Oregon State to some of them and so I always just like books
and I don't know I like to books and graduate school I always like to read and
then mainly when we moved to Washington in Maryland actually I should say
in DC suburb I got interested in older books rare books the friend mine was
also interested so we sort of got involved in that together back in the in the in the 80s
and got sort of collecting you know significant volumes back in the late 80s I think and
got interested in the history of printing was fascinating and how how that affected
our culture in my mind that's the ability to print disseminate the information really had a
profound effect on our culturally vulnerable religion with you know education and
change change change change how we live and they think and they allowed
everybody if they could learn to read to have access to information and led to things like the
reformation and the real cultural changes and then not to speak about how it affected
education if you think about it before the printed book getting a book was very very difficult
getting knowledge was very very definitely good lecture because someone had read something
but to get a copy of a scholarly work prior to the learning of the printing press you had to be
both enough to hire somebody to do it by hand to get to get to get that so the average person
even though the professional person probably wouldn't have any volumes back prior to the printing
process but the printing press was in my mind it was a great liberating thing for for changing
culture and it did and I just sort of interested in that got interested in the technology of printing
and and then of course some of the the volumes are just beautiful and a wonderful look at and
how they were and how they preserved I always found that fascinating too you can buy a book that's
500 years old and open it up and it probably looks as you know someone look as good as the day they
were they were printed like one of the books that the library has is a 5003 Seneca it's in Latin
but it's of Seneca's works and that paper is as fresh as the day it was made there's no Fox
you know a lot of books the paper a lot of Fox you know it's just a change in the character of the
paper but the they last forever it seems like so it's just a it's a fascinating technology but
just keeping in mind the the the profound impact it had upon on our civilization and how we
write what we are now now it's comparable change in the last couple decades of how this electronic
environment electronically delivered information is going to affect culture remains to be seen
and how that integrates into the educational process and and in our general cultural
behavior so it will be an interesting thing I probably won't live long enough to see the outcome
of the orbital it's an it's a profound change and how people can get information and how you
deliver information and so things will slowly evolve as they certainly did in the late 15th
century when the printing press became available and now education everything changed to
profoundly tell me a bit about your methods for collecting that scouting out and purchasing and
I got a topical thing either if I could get early science things that's in my science as I always
would get that if if I something I could afford and then it primarily was in history I was always
at some interest in history and in the history of printing so I have some of the volumes I have
about purely because they were from a given printer and and and and and and town like Venice or
whatever from the from maybe the 16th century that would be representative of that kind of printing
that that that era so some of the books with that and then their role in scholarly works to like
the Seneca I mentioned earlier and then there's this another nice volume I give you the
Straybo Geography which is a early early production of a Straybo who was a Roman Geographer's
commentaries and maps of the ancient world that book is complete with all the diagram maps and
diagrams and so forth and so it's fascinating to Venice and both Greek and Latin and it's fascinating
just to look at that and see the the the the Romans concept of the way the world was I mean in the
master actually fairly accurate with the curvature there's totally displayed and so on and so on so
the it tells you it just shows you just quite graphically how how you know how almost the ancient
really knew about the world and they weren't as as it's ignorant as it's sometimes portrayed
so I I get to kick in and then the some of the early scientific stuff too there's a
copy of it's in French and Ben Frank was working on electricity and that was published I don't
think with the reposition in this country was published in France when he was we spent
time in France and so it was a little inside into and to Ben Frank's time as a as a Franco
file I mean serving the country in France so it's some early Newton that's just it's absolutely
fascinating I think and there's some other interesting early scientific books as well
I think they're interesting but the scholarly things are some good histories you know and
it's a good collection of Johnson the writer poet and his biography Boswell you have a nice set
of a really nice early early productions and publications and that's here so that's a
important part of the cultural history of the English-speaking people well it's things like that
would track my interest as well as the quite a few travel books so the early travel books people
back in the 16th and 17th century no woman would finance someone to take a trip through the
orient or through the northern Africa the Levant or something and and record it record the customs
of the people and also take along either do it themselves or take along someone to do engravings
and drawings and then make these nice nice printed copies of their travels so when I run across
those if there were a good shape I would try and procure those as well because there was an
interesting insight into the culture and history and in those time frames well those those kinds
of things as well I found interesting and sometimes books are just beautiful I mean they're
printed beautiful and the bindings and good shape and you just say well I gotta have that
well I know that you've taken pride in the fact that you actually read these books too you'll
purchase them and put them on the shelf yeah exactly in fact I can continue to do so even I gave
working state the majority see this right over here is a deflected in the last couple of years
eventually you'll end up in your library but I've got a for example even in the other room I say
on the stand trial often said I got a really nice Bible the one of the first complete English
Bible is printed in the United States in fact it's generally thought to be like 1796 the first
complete Bible and I've some earlier just new Old Testament and and New Testament's published but
this is a complete Bible called the Collins Bible I believe with the Old Testament New Testament
all the books of the paragraph are all bound in one and it's a really good shape so that's
something I came across just just recently in last year or so and there's a big thick book of
theirs is Plutarch's lies and early Plutarch's lies in English so that's fun to sit down and read
Plutarch was across the Roman bog for back back and so you want to know by Julius Caesar Alexander
the great of these people that have early early early printing of Plutarch of course you
can go down people a paperback now the same thing but here's a nice early publication of Plutarch
we spent three decades just compiling this collection they made decisions at some point to
donate it to your alma mater urban state will tell me about the thought process there
well I knew neither one of my kids is really interested in rare books per se of course they'd
be interested in the value that they're up I mean that goes without saying right I mean they
have to be hindered mentally if they didn't want that you know but the if you have a collection
like that and people with collections often have this this issue as you get older so how do I do
you know what's going to be the ultimate disposal if we my wife and I both pass will pass away
if these books were still sitting in the house the children wouldn't know how to you know they don't
pick them off them in their house but what would they do with them well they would call of some
estate agent right and then they would sell on somebody being here buying a five thousand dollar
book for fifty cents right and that's not too smart the other option well well I could start
selling it on myself that is truly a legal option you could do it and you might or might not
realize very much money but the the beauty of the donation is you can have them appraised by
a good appraiser and they stayed together there's a collection in the case of that's what we've
worked up for at Oregon State so others will use them so it was very satisfying when you were
and or somebody tells me how the students are using that was the intent so we decided that rather
than trying to sell them or something I think well given to Oregon State the benefit to us is
it's a tax deduction so we get to realize a tax deduction since it's a large sum over over
over a period of time and and and and help us out financially so actually probably in the end
that's probably more rewarding financially than trying to sell them in all that headache plus
the main thing is they stay together there's a collection for others to use again as long as I
like in the car and drive down on myself you see so I we thought it was we thought about it a while
and and we finally decided that was the part of the best strategy and then Mr. Meek came up
and looked them over and then he said that I'm arranged with your librarian Faye to accept
the collection and and so it's worked out excellent and we're really satisfied because the staff
of Oregon State is just super in the library and then it's been served the students there because
I was a student there and I don't think there was anything like that there when I was there
if there was I was not cognizant of it so if we can benefit the kids of this state or whoever
that's that's very satisfying and the main thing is something we spend a long time
massing and then to have it just go to all with the and try and sell it it's it's not that's rewarding
it is financially but that wouldn't mean that much to us I mean we're comfortable with retirement
another few thousand dollars when we was at this point in our life is not going to be particularly
beneficial so it's much more satisfying to do what we did and of course I applaud Oregon State
immediately and part because that's where I was graduated from and I liked it the great deal
I have very fond members of Oregon State but also one of my friends probably got me thinking about
was it was Derek Callahan who was on the alumni or association the foundation for a while and
he was he didn't raise the issue about Donnie but he told me about the kind of things he did
you know really helping the university raise money and so forth and that sort of sparked my
mind well maybe that's something we could do you know I helped the university out by
so we contacted Derek put us in contact with something in the foundation and
and I'll Ryan is Ryan Robinson at the time and and working with he and the and the library staff
with me and so forth we made the arrangements so we we have found a very satisfying
the last thing I want to ask you about is your continued connection to OSU you're never the
library advisory council OSU is in the midst of a transition expansion right now what is your
sense of where OSU is at right now a very different place from the one that you went to it's
certainly yes and I think what you what the faith in the rest of you've done to the library is
just phenomenal I mean the library was not at all like that when I was a student here and trying
to transition and take advantage of the modern electronic tools and make it space for the for the
students to use I'm always impressed when I go down to the places pack I was sure you back
back in the 60s you find a few people pointed over the line but that wasn't a lot so you've
turned it into a central learning experience with space for the kids you know I think it's
terrible important so I think this you got the transitional library to a to a really a part
of the learning environment for a large number of students it's sort of exciting it's fun to be a
part of so my wife and I were very interested in helping out in any way we can and of course we've
had a lot of experience with books and in education and in conveying information so we think we'd be
using some value well thank you very much for this I appreciate quite a lot well thank you
here's some good fun to help out